and why is there a contradiction
in the end of the proof was the
contradictions at 9k is bigger than K
yeah so the contradiction is that we got
at every degree is not louder than 9k
mm-hmm but we know that every degree is
the same as top entrance right and this
by assumption of the theorem is at most
K another way to say the triple the
contradiction is to say you got 0.14
your mass below level 10k and the open
wound above level 10 case oh no the open
to but this is a probability yes but you
would probably want to and it's good to
say it how you said it because then
you're generalizing it doesn't but yeah
but this is we are now recording it and
let's stop yeah sure and feel free to
start okay so hi all for those of you
returned for more so now I'm going to
tell you a little bit about our and the
way we will do it is bit don't stutter
standard so I'm not really going to give
you too many concrete statements I'm
going to explain to you what is the
process so what we're going to see some
improvement process that starts with the
KCAL theorem and ends up with some
unclear inequality but I'm going to tell
you this unclean quality is good but if
you want to remember just one sentence
from this second part of the talk is the
following so it's about college
[Music]
inequalities so like what do you mean by
that so I claim that the poof we've just
seen for the kicker to him
the bulk of it really all of it boil
down to a single population equality
saying that under some conditions the
correlation between F in some logic we
know me Allah is smaller so let me state
it so yeah Salima one so I can relate to
this lemma we essentially pulled in the
first part of the talk and so for this
part I'll sprinkle in some cheats and
lies and if you catch it then you can
ask about it and I promise to answer but
otherwise I'm going to ignore it so so
what is the problem then one one says it
if you have a boil function and you have
some which is the clean and you know
that the influence of all variables of
the audio part is smaller okay so so now
when you say that so this function is is
not going on so we didn't really define
what influences out for non boolean
functions but it's something that is to
do so let's just do it
so with your general function it's not
cool if the video is going to hold up
button
yeah so if you have a general function
when you're the variable then the
influence of lalibela on G is what you
sort of expect it to be so again you
look at this difference
you win / - let's say squirrel meat
expectation so this is how you
generalize inferences for general
functions so everyone says that if all
of the low degree influences are small
then the correlation between X and the
lowly clip out of Earth's is it trust
Delta to the 1/8 times exponential in D
times little paint fanciful and so I
hope that when you look at it it seems
like something that we almost bought in
the first hour and it - how to see that
I can indeed both using the same tools
but it is you know just a correlation in
quality it says that the coalition -
it'll only give power is small and I
claimed that dude is still balanced yeah
so f will always be balanced
[Music]
also in this part yeah so if the
inequality just not true for an
unbalanced function or just not tight
well then you need to care about the
empty coefficient separately good so
what do you want to say yeah so I claim
that the ball can occur in this
inequality which is what does not allow
us to prove strong statements then
kicker is the exponential dependency on
D
we could improve this exponential
dependency something better let's say e
to the Wadley or maybe even Polly ding
then would be very happy and this would
imply great things the problem is that
it's false and in fact this is tight but
still what we are going to do now in
this part of dog is we're going to try
to improve this correlation equality and
the fact that it's not possible should
not tell you you should still think you
should start still try to do things even
though they are not super possible yeah
I don't know what good so so another
point that I want to make is that in
this part of the talk I'm going to only
state like correlation equalities but I
promise to you that a such coalition
equalities give you bounds on the phone
and you will see kind of easily that you
will get bound for the minion dopey but
I claim that you can also get for the
Fortuner interval but will not see it
explicitly
yeah so we said that our bottleneck is
would the connection between correlation
equalities and the entropy are the main
entropy does it rely on F being boolean
or its sister no so the question quite
itself relies on FB in boolean right and
then go to yeah because the base case is
sort of cake error but is a sort of
hinted in the first part of the talk you
can actually prove aliens for like
bounded functions ah right that's a bit
I guess the question is is it like you
said that the correlation equality is
the same as entropy like the related to
then you can get entropy bounds and so
on and that part also does it need to
use boolean nests or is it good
it was another question door asking if
you can explain what you mean by the
bomb like here so what what I mean by
that is that if you told me that this
inequality holds we've like e to the
would that's the good thing
then you'd improve KKL immediately you
you can get bounds for a better bounds
for literally any resulting we our
analysis the choices and yeah you could
prove many things but it's needed
yeah but it's tight so you need to to
find out where you found it yeah so what
is the blue good so we'll this question
quality and the bottleneck is that the
dependency on the degree is too large we
cannot and we know they too cannot
circumvent that so naturally idea would
be okay so maybe we
we apply this hydro conductivity
business maybe we can reduce the degree
of the function so that even though it's
exponential in degree the degree would
be smaller and this way we'll prove
something a bit stronger so little humor
a try to reduce the degree of the load
is part of fresh fio2
good so how do you do it again optional
so to do that there is a very standard
tool a tool called random stations which
we present next and so suppose we have
some function and we have a set of
variables set of codons then for any
fixing of the valid code X outside the
set a we can define the restricted
function which takes the inputs as input
a setting for the coordinates of a and
this is defined in a most natural sense
what you do is when you put Y you look
at F at the point why is it what I mean
that the a part will be filled out by Y
and the complement will be filled out
wizard
good so I do random restrictions help us
with legal deductions so let's look at
things clothing so suppose we have this
F smaller than the function so we write
it in its Fourier racing's and now this
monomial will spit it according to the
rebels that are in a and where it bends
it outside a so now note that if I look
at the restricted function well the
complement of a goes to Z then this part
will be some constant so only this part
will remain a level so what I'm saying
here is that the monomial corresponding
to s we really collapse down to the
monomial of corresponding to s
intersection a therefore you can expect
the degree of the restriction to go down
if you discard cuz a typically smaller
and this is indeed the hope so a what do
you have in mind is suppose we want to
reduce maybe three oh I've smelled in D
2 V which is much smaller than then what
you can do is choose a random link by
including each variable with a
the overdue then typically when you have
s the t's of size Tomas team will have
that s intersection area is typically of
size H mostly okay so actually if you
want to get a good deduction you need to
do a little more than that but but for
the purpose of this talk we'll sort of
assume that if you do a new accession
according to this way lucky to get a
bigger deduction so assumption a you can
do this sort of fun with station and get
the Green Street function down too
awfully so so i sees it like the average
degree would just to see what okay but
you're gonna use this stronger
assumption that yeah so as I said I'm
going to sprinkle in many chicks and
doing this part of a talk so this is
kind of the first cheat and thank you I
wish I ho catching it so what you'll
need to do is you'll need to follow a
characters they do not behave this way
if you really want to get the easy to go
down but to argue that you can do that
it's it's a bit messy so I don't want to
do it okay good a very good and so
another thing that we want to do is we
want a more general type of collation
inequality so instead of talking about
college so when you do the random
description if you had a truly symmetric
function and you won't get any much
degree restriction reduction but because
the font on the other hand if a function
f is sparse in the Fourier world then
you get more degree deduction do you in
when you said this
assumption that you're gonna make the
exam are you are you gonna use this
paucity of f also in the proof here in
specially like you're trying to prove
some kind of spicy to the Fourier
spectrum of F are you also going to need
to prove use as positive some beakers
positive for a spectrum of F in making
this assumption precise or is that again
generate is that yes
so tell you what I need so what I need
is that when I forward characters that
do not go down enough by the animal
section the mass that I have there is
not everything is like at most half of
what I ever so in that sense it's really
generic you don't need a spotter or
anything like that so so for that it's
just enough to reduce the average degree
let's say P over 2 and then apply Marcos
right yeah yeah okay and and and let you
get I mean that's what happens random
restrictions yeah so again you probably
see now that we will have to do a lot of
massaging to function so it doesn't
really make sense to talk about the
corrosion between F and the low degree
part of F because all going to change it
so much that it's going to forget what
started out is so enjoy a so we'll
consider also a bipartite version of the
coalition in quality so let me state it
now lemma 1 prime which is really the
same as number 1 but it's the back of
that reduction so we have boolean
function we have a lovely little
function we know that all of the
inferences effect respond then coalition
between a Frenchman is it most and data
to the 1/8 x and it will be and
something that looks like the total
influence
we call it the cost to the inference so
let's let me find quickly it's not it's
not a big deal so this cost reference is
the sum of all four variables
of the geometric average of interest and
so so really the same proof lemma one
walks to show that not it's not a
meeting okay good so now that we click
stop the statement let's try to execute
our doing plan on freaks again their
intuition behind what I of FG is
it's an intuition behind it like what's
this take when you understand what
influences right this one really looks
yes I don't have any any intuition about
it a what I can tell you is that it
behaves well and the ramifications and
you can always bound it by the product
of the influences oh the geometric
average talking Frances but it's not
clear if there is any good heed to what
it measures good good so now now we try
to execute our game plan but so will
this lemma one time and what to improve
it by first reduced in the beginning
then using the side contractivity
business which will be invoking lemma 1
prime itself so let's do it
so whether our function f and D and we
choose our set of flight variables
randomly as we did before and the size
of the set of liabilities as we said
earlier roughly V over D times n yeah so
how can we express the correlation
between F and G is a function of
correlations of the expections well this
is very easy it's the expected coalition
of stations
okay good so now we sort of got all the
gear reduction the degree of this
remember we think about it as a day so
now for each of the kinsey we can invoke
our load it the argument we can invoke
lemma one climb so we have this Delta
which is the maximum influence of and we
don't confuse something
[Music]
so is it now that you reduce t2v that's
yeah so yeah so we have this data which
is the maximum influence assess it but
now remember the B is relieving
times exponentially nuclear but again
the degree is now week and this course
influence term good so it looks very
good so don't worry about is this is the
this always behaves very nicely
it seems like we improved our situation
here dramatically but this guy is a bit
of a pain so why is that well we know
that if you look at a so a mess the
government so we know that if you look
at fixed tire and you look at the
influence of the strict function then
typically it will be the same as before
the restriction okay - this is - an
expectation but what could be the case
may be for each fixing Z there is a
different variable whose inference
suddenly becomes very large
so maybe it can happen and in fact it's
not only maybe it will happen because we
we know again for the function that will
some variable with high influence yes so
this seems like okay so what will you do
so so don't just to make sure that we're
on the same page so when you say an
expectation do you mean over only Zed or
both a and that was it so I think of a
is like no fixed so I will fix it we fix
it so that we did have the declared
optional okay now the only thing is the
fixing the busy I see okay so so this is
sort of the reason you cannot execute
this trim plan very clearly because you
have this so formally you have this
expedition the maximum and you cannot
really interchange in them and actually
we soon see that you can interchange
them but it's costly you need to pay
against some hyperactivity constant but
but but this is what doesn't allow the
both to go through but still let's look
at the typical now what we have before
us to him is that all variables have low
influence in after the restriction most
variables remain with low influence but
maybe a select few suddenly have high
influence
so this suggests that maybe we should
try to cool some other inequality some
other correlation inequality that
address functions not only have very
base with law in France but maybe they
have a few variables with high influence
so this is limited so we have a low
degree function and we have some
parameter Delta greater than 0 but now I
don't assume anything about the
influences then the correlation between
F and G is it most the same expression
is where before Delta to the 1/8 times
exponential individually thank this is
close inference term so this what will
come out of the labels with low
influence but now we have to count what
comes out of flowerbeds with high
influence and for that we use a very
cool bound so what you get is the
quantization for variables with have
influences most and the over Delta 2
reading so actually I want to learn I
want to say 1 over delta T it will give
it clearing about oh never mind
times the maximum flow coefficient so
this is a way
to pull a general coalition in equality
when you don't assume anything about the
influences and I want to show you
quickly the proof of this lemma
okay it's a coke sketch so how do you do
it well if you identify the set of
variables that have high influence and
then what you do is you look at the
correlation you know that it is by
gradual is equal to the sum of products
of four coefficients now you split this
product according to whether the
calculus contains an influential
variable Oh whether all of its a sorry
whether it contains a low influence
level whether all fits variables with
high entrance so formally what I want to
say is that this is most with some
coefficients that are completely
contained in high influence else
whatever comes out of low influence so
for that we take first available with
low inference then we sum over all
characters that contain it in we above
expression okay so I sort of want to
stop here but I will just tell you how
you finish it so to study something like
that you apply exactly the same argument
as indicated
/ OS lemma one and this one gives you
this standard camera now about this
well how many characters are there that
contained in H so remember the G of is
of degree at most D so that at most like
H to the D many such cartels so we can
clearly bound it by the number of them
times the maximum and I only need to say
is that this H is not allowed in indeed
you can show that the size of H is not
to launch its most good and yeah so this
is this is the booth and actually so I
want to make one remark due to a
question of posted earlier so in this
argument this is the only place that we
are going to use the boolean any of this
like the rest of the argument is going
to be fairly generic good great so now
we have a more general equation equality
that applies to all functions it's not
necessary that you have all if not only
variables having glowing francs so now
let's try to a really cute our plan
great but before that I want to sort of
make a small jump and which again can be
justified
so for these arguments it would be very
convenient for us to think of G not only
is it loaded in function but it's a
function that is all of its characters
roughly of the same size so because this
is dope I can need let's even assume
that the most optimistic thing happens
let's say that the G is homogeneous
you
so it's not going to it's not just a big
jump you can sort of split do you always
according to degrees by factors of 2 and
3 each one separately but for now this
is enough for us and also what we'll
assume is that so remember the 1200s
anyway the set of flight levels so we
will also assume that after you be
strict the function still remains
homogeneous again you need to argue that
this is actually you can actually get to
a situation like that it's not a big
deal cool so with this out of the way we
can try to execute our plan so we want
to bound the correlation between F and G
so exactly as we did earlier we're going
to write it as the expected correlation
between the randomization of F and the
random positions again but now because
we don't know anything about the
influences of F well instead going to
apply lemma to
so we have a standard time but remember
the lemon is now applied with D which is
really weak so we have this tunnel time
which is never going to cause any
trouble for us but now we have this
waited for a term with the Fourier
coefficients good so now let's do it
know just to simplify our lives so we
can clearly bound this for a coefficient
by one because even the restriction of
this is the boolean function so all of
its coefficients of at most one
and as I told you the other term is
never the problem and you can actually
bound the expectation of this guy by the
way general costs influence of F and G
so this is not going to cause any new
carpet for us so let's even forget about
it good so what we did we get here so
now again we got into some problem with
expectation and wave this maximum we
don't know much to say about it like we
placed influences with Fourier
coefficients so it seems like we're
stuck with the same problem but actually
what I want to claim is that we did make
some progress at least intuitively with
it and by that I mean that you can
expect these four coefficients to be
much much smaller than what you could
expect the inferences to be and the way
to see that is by the following fact
yeah so one of the only things that we
know about for coefficients of the
electrical functions is about their
expectation and about the square of the
expectation so this is a the only thing
that we're going to use so if you look
at the expected four coefficients of f
of F G when you randomize over Z then
this is exactly the sum of four
coefficients of G that when intersected
with the set of fly variables give us
okay so this is not how to cover and not
do it
I just want to I'll do that this fact in
it least intuitively tells us that we
did get a significantly better bound
potentially so why is that so remember
when you look at the influences what you
really have is summation of four
characters that contain a certain
variable but now when you have this guy
you contain many many variables right
because this is by our assumption so we
assumed that even after the restriction
dilemma in Java genius and this is still
fairly large okay so potentially this
expected square the Fourier coefficients
are much much smaller than influences so
it's much smaller than what we could
expect although previous attempts
so there is still a chance that they
will get something interesting and
indeed this is what you like what you
get so how do you use this fact so we
still have this problem that we have the
maximum expectation it's not clear what
we can do about it
but but you can do something about it so
so we want to bound expected maximum for
a coefficient sorry we had a quick
correction slash question that the
factory that hats in it so I someone
pointed out in the the fact should have
hats in it yeah let me see thank you and
yeah so we want to bound this maximum we
only know something about the square but
this is fine we can use a again sir
good but now we still have this maximum
an expectation problem and here is a
very interesting fact and very important
which also this if you remember this
battles began collide that I mentioned
earlier they use this fact terror so it
turns out that you can interchange the
maximum in expectation but you have to
pay something
is the degree of you have to be
exponential in the degree of the
function which makes a restriction to
the Fourier coefficient of the
corresponding a restriction so in other
words you have to pay you some
exponential in D SAPO
okay so let's put all of these things
together when we do that we get them
SoDo just just out of curiosity how
complicated it is you know
interpretation is one line thing that
you roll things they say oh Jenny I
should maximum yeah it's actually very
simple it's it's huge I can show you
that to understand how complicated but
so we have a boolean function in our
homogeneous function Jing and we have
another parameter V which is the
typically we will reduce to and
whatsoever they span the Delta then if
you want to bound the correlation
between F and G you can do it and the
bound is you having a standard term now
we have this complicated term which we
walked kind of hard to get so you have
some 1 over Delta to the dream and then
you have dismay and expected maximum for
a coefficient and we manipulate it quite
a lot to get something to be simpler
more complicated depends how you look at
it and finally we got some influences
looking looking thing but which is
potentially much smaller
okay so this is what we got and so now
I'd like to pause here so it's already
getting quite heavy with annotations and
I want to convince you that this
inequality is a little not worse than
what we started out with so remember
with this lemma one
you
you
yeah so we started with lemma one which
says very similar bound way except
instead of this inference is looking
fine you actually have influences
Robbie's Delta's stood for influences
but now we're something much better will
influence of the coalition of variables
where this which is potentially much
smaller so the way you should think
about this statement is telling you that
if all coalition's have small influences
then you can improve lemma one
significantly until that is small is
much smaller then the influences then
you improve the morning good now if you
think about it like not to too much with
these notations you see that we sort of
made a circular we started with the
statement telling us that if all
influences are small then you have a
correlation in quality and they ended up
with a standard telling us that if all
coalition's are small all questions have
small influence then you get an
improving equality so it makes sense
indeed you can do it that another step
of this process
you can sort of lift this assumption
that all of the collisions have small
influence and instead say a collision
inequality about general the general
case and this is finally a lemma for and
maybe not intuitively but it's going to
be the derivation is very similar to
what we've seen but but you still need
to be careful and you actually need like
a one more idea but I hope that feeling
is clear so we have a wave function
hello modulus function will be which is
typically we going to reduce to with our
Delta and we have a parameter Delta tool
which is much smaller than Delta and if
you think about it as the influence of
collisions then the correlation between
F and G is its most first of all we have
a standard camera then with what comes
out of collisions with small influence
which is very similar to the standard
term but it's a bit different
and finally with what comes out of
coalition's that have high influence so
this is something you can prove using
what we've seen so far and so I don't
you like it first look how does it seem
maybe it seems like incomprehensible or
something like that but but actually
this is all useful so so if you have
this statement alone you can only read
improve like the same squirrel we do all
of that so limit for you can already get
someone to the results you can show that
the minion true thing squared is it most
influence to some power so I think that
what you get is silver - but not super
sure and actually this is not like this
is maybe in Excel
next exercise it's not too hard to
figure out using explain my loan
if you walk little harder then you can
also go something about the Shannon
entropy again the day then the general
fee the German thing female is similar
you get slightly worse bounce then how
many results so you get something like
summation over s is to be three over two
coefficient squared and also you
similar result for chopped flesh wounds
but this is the based on the lemma for
ya
so how to go beyond that okay
Doreen can you say maybe I mean I I can
see how you get the H like the mean
entropy because in some sense mean
entropy says that there exists a big we
a coefficient how do you get from that
to the Shannon thing maybe you can say
just yeah catch so how do you get the
shine on so what you do is you split the
four coefficients of F according to the
magnitude and then for each like so you
split them say okay let's look at all a
doctor that size D and first of all I'm
going to look at characters whose a
magnitude is like to the minus D then
I'm going to look at cocktails with not
used to it annex to D and so on each one
of them I'm going to to account their
contribution to the entropy and to
account that I'm going to use this
collation inequality you say that there
is no too much mass on such cartels so
this is like the one line explanation of
how you use this coalition inequality to
get entropy bounds it's really not super
difficult but but you need to do some
calculations a good so don't worry we're
not going to see how to go beyond it and
before I'm just going to say like a few
words so what we've seen the second part
of the dog is really Portis silly some
sort of boosting process is the pocket
it starts out out with the KKK filling
in the form of them or in getting a very
similar statement which is stone them
so I stopped there why why not invoke
this process again and again and again
and again then say start with lemma for
do this a process get lemma 8 be
something you can do and this is how we
do it
oh if you are not super careful about
this process you get some bound which is
like influence to the 1 plus epsilon for
every epsilon and I refer to like let's
say for the minute
yeah do each step of the boosting
process involve a new random restriction
yeah and but it's it but it is just
boosting the lemma statement some we are
not really doing all the restrictions
it's done in that building it's done so
if you're working I'm level the
induction let me do all of these are no
restrictions but yeah it's best the best
way to look at it is I think as an
iterative process like you do wander on
my station you get them before you do
another one you get they my eight and so
on yeah and each time you do it you know
the Stegner's gets more and more messy
like you see that after one you get to
this unclear terms which are clear if
you stare at it for a while but get more
and more and more and like you know
there are a lot of issues you need to
start worrying about many details that I
didn't discuss so this is this is why
you get stuck at 1 plus epsilon but not
1 plus epsilon you have like 1 over
epsilon different levels of coalition's
or influence or something about yeah and
if you want to get further
you need to be already like much more
careful you need to be very careful not
to waste anything so for example just to
point out one place so earlier when we
wanted to simplify our lives we said
something like oh the photo coefficient
of Earth is at most 1 let's go it away
so if you do something like that you
never get to log you'll always get stuck
in some 1 plus epsilon and but if you
want to get a log unit remote - you need
to do some other tricks but but really
the core idea is still the same it's
some boasting statement and good let me
clap still like two more minutes to tell
you some open questions yes oh one k all
the question is there like to prove a
result I can maybe the entire conduction
so personally I'm optimistic that for
entropy something that is within reach
but before the public for a while and we
couldn't see how to get rid of this log
so see something that we want to do and
secondly bit less specifically so our
argument involves lots of random
extinctions in on restrictions of
something that we studied in Theseus for
a long time especially in the Khan
text of racism so the question is can
you perhaps
combine the ideas that go there and
there are ideas that we have to get
better results for a sub classes of
functions lastly so actually what we've
seen in this talk we haven't seen bounds
on the four end okay we'll see miss
collation inequalities and it makes
sense that maybe those will be added
some other applications of this
coalition in qualities because they seem
like fairly general
and yeah so that's all I wanted to say
for this talk so thank you very much for
sticking with until the very end and
thank you for listening thank you door
it was wonderful thank you so much very
it seems that you are really getting
stuck at the same like if you consider
DNFs or with WD NFS then it was known to
be like wo w and i guess you get
something you get a new pro for that so
do you think there isn't some something
inherent it that this is like a really
challenging case that reveals the
challenge of the entire conjecture it's
hard to tell to say I don't know what
the answer to this question is but like
for the nerves
you have the lot more going for you you
have exponentially carefully
coefficients which you never have in
general case and so it seems like yeah
I'm not sure what to say right in fact
in some sense you can prove the W log W
using the exponential decay yeah yeah
yeah and I guess this is a good what you
refer to as money through conjecture so
there to go from W log W / W is a DNF so
the tight example for your full
correlation inequality you however they
are tight examples for this for the full
correlation equality yeah so we never
attempted to save to say if it's tight
like you
but it's for tribes it makes sense to
check it for tribesmen yeah I see my
door is right Lisa can you do sir
okay another question so a slightly
different way to strengthen lemma one
prime where you have this maximum
influence could be that I mean the
maximum influence is just the L infinity
norm of the vector of influences and can
you replace it possibly by the four norm
or some large P norm or yes and just
fall for usually yes this is like if you
want to get the log then instead of
looking at maximum for coefficients you
have to look some other norms like some
other pin ohms so this is like one of
these things that go into pushing it to
logo so I will be fasting actually even
before the Fourier coefficient already
in the influence I don't really think
that you'll get too much because like
instead of getting like data today 1/8
you get some other power but it wouldn't
change too much I think the assumption
could be right let's respect you because
you don't need your senses the maximum
is yeah right yeah so then you don't
have to worry about whether all
coordinates have small influence after
the restriction v but just the fourth
norm of influence is a small after the
restriction yeah let's go but but yeah
but like interchange then you endeavour
to interchange the expectation I mean
this power at some point which is kind
of similar to change change expected in
the maximum so whatever you try to go
with it it sort of thing get to the same
point I think all there's a question in
the chat
yes so the question is in the argument
you described you have B as you
described it essentially a free
parameter and then then finally in lemma
for there you get a deal over V term
would suggest oh well you probably want
to optimize it are there other
constraints on it in this argument
because I know you swept some things
under the rug yeah so so so the way I
stated it I don't think there is any
constraint so there is tension between
like this term and this term check oh
the first one you want to take Velarde
but for the second one we take want to
take v smaller so like the way to
optimize is to think to choose like V
which is equal to square root of D sure
sure but there's no other constraint
other than that in some sense it seems
that what you showed us is how to get
from the fact that you have you know big
influence like at least e to the minus T
for one coordinate showing that there
exists a set of like square root T
coordinates with four marks to contain
all of them is also roughly the same
right so in some sense what you're
saying is it's enough for a coefficient
to be to contribute small it's enough
that one of its variables is small
influence in some sense this is actually
what's going on you know and then the
same goes for coalition's of Genuity
which is the main point
so you said you will show us the
expectation max interchange and if it's
short perfect there's something yeah
yeah so for it so we are G which is the
creep mostly
and want to analyze the expected value
on the maximum squirrel or for a
proficient
anyway stick it okay so what you do is
saying it's very cute
first of all bounded maximum by sum of
4th powers square root then you push the
repetition inside remember when you're
like want to lean out to looks so then
you use hydro conductivity to bound this
form with the to normal
and here you play some explanation in
the degree and I will do the standard
manipulation will you call outside some
the maximum value yeah and this you can
show is the by using barrier fact of
what are they expected and scores for
coefficients you can show that this is
most the two norm of G so this is how
you do this is all you need to change
the maximum expectation and you pay
exponential and it's a little short
[Music]
sorry how did you pull replace the
summation of the max aim in the final
step in the second one so here what I
did is I have the square of this
expectation oh yes oh but one of them
are put upside is the maximum
it's very impressive that so many people
drown for more than two hours so it's
really complement to door
okay great I guess I'll stop recording
and if you want to ask questions offline
you can do it now I had one question do
any of these questions make sense over
other distributions over like other than
uniform yeah so I forgot hoodies is an
open question but there is the other
thing that I really like which is a
wholly PBS scenario specifically well so
one piece bounded away from 0 1 the
picture is the same but when P is small
then the picture changes and you don't
you no longer to talk about hunters but
you talk about some other things
DNA formulas and I think that it's very
interesting to ask whether you can do
something like that over there papaya
distribution will appear smaller like
the statements themselves you need to
exchange them but we don't know how to
sort of transfer this go through so
stuck to that there is a same expect of
would free tote with in appendix by
bogum the dust something like the
squared we've seen in the beginning for
the pivot reservation but we don't know
how to do the book stinger and but still
there too there is also this paper by
Hamid and what I made it
that's something else but again there is
the squirrels but to answer your
question I think that it's interesting
Thanks so in your entire talk today you
never use did you use f not equal to G
yeah so if you think about it like in
the in the beginning G was the
truncation of F but time we made a
restriction and I did Sadie but you
needed to clean up gene a little bit
because some things remain of hiding e
because i'll annoying so we for them
away so then every time you changes a
little bit so this is why it's very
convenient sort of think about that
version okay thank you so much tour